at what point is it appropriate to bring
in a guru or a story consultant or maybe
it's not there's this debate whether
someone that's never really had a lot of
scripts made teaching others yeah seems
strange but then there's others who are
better teachers than they are doers well
and there's a lot of snake oil salesmen
so I think you have to do your research
my whole thing with consultants there
are a lot of very good ones and and
quite a few that are great friends of
mine that I would recommend to anybody
but I always think when you're looking
for a consultant you should the the best
way to go about it is asked that
consultant for contacts of their clients
so you could reach out to them and ask
them how they feel like a contractor
yeah and if they're not willing to give
you that then move on but when is it
okay we know when is it appropriate I
think it's another problem that
screenwriters have and I think this is
another problem with some of the books I
think you have to have a lot of trust in
yourself and I know that that's not easy
for a writer it isn't it's not easy for
any creative we all have doubt and cope
Lou
you know said famously if you don't have
fear then you're not a true creative
doesn't matter what your skill level is
but at some point you have to embrace
that fear okay and you have to say I
feel pretty good about this I feel
pretty good about the story I feel
pretty good about the structure I feel
pretty good about my three acts I feel
pretty good about my inciting incident
my arcs everything and now what I like
to do is bring in somebody that I can
trust that is going to be and this is
key
brutally you know fierce about this work
you know and be honest with me and not
gonna blow smoke up my skirt and say you
know it's fantastic okay and that of
course means that you don't go to your
mom and you don't go to your family and
you know your mom's not gonna tell you
have third-act problems it's not gonna
know yep so you got to go to somebody
that you know that you trust and
somebody who is gonna be honest with
their with their feedback but I think
that you have to make the decision when
you're ready I used to have sort of a
rule of thumb when I first started it's
a little different now because with the
state stories you have the writers were
working directly with executives so I
can get my work if I want somebody to
critique my work I could even pay for it
through my own site to pay for somebody
to you know of of stature to look at the
work but before we had this and before
the site was even online
I had a coverage service that was a very
very
general inexpensive but well you know
well respected coverage service and I
would send and this is usually after my
you know second or third draft I would
send my screenplay
I would buy three pieces of coverage
from from that particular cover service
if one person had a comment the negative
comment on something I'd look at it if
two people had the same notes I'd really
really look at it and I probably would
change it if three people came back I
knew I had a problem okay if all three
people came back with the same thing and
then I had one trusted advisor that I
had cultivated a relationship with who
covered screenplays for studios for 20
years somebody I found online somebody
that I had done my due diligence on set
it and you know and went to him and he
was like my last line of defense
okay so once I corrected all the
problems from the first three pieces of
coverage I trusted myself enough to say
okay I can't be Precious about this
anymore I got to let it go I'm gonna let
him read it and I know now the knives
are gonna come out and I trust him okay
I totally trust him and I trusted him
enough that we had the type of
relationship and this is again by going
to people that he work with I asked this
question if he pushes back on me even if
he pushes on me can I push back and will
he be receptive to me pushing back
because I don't want to just you know
give in I want to know I want have a
little bit of a debate about it if I
really feel strong about it and by the
way that's gonna serve you well if you
become a working writer because you know
you're gonna want to accept things but
you're gonna want it you're gonna pick
your fights you're gonna fight for
certain things you know and he would and
he you know the answer was yes he will
like he'll allow you to go back so he
would always be my last line in defense
I would work with him take his notes go
back clean it up and then at that point
I was out I was trying to you know query
executives and query managers or
submitting it to contests and everything
I was wasn't Precious about it anymore
and I wasn't reworking like if I
submitted it to festivals or not the
festivals to contests or the managers or
whatever I wasn't reworking it at that
point like now it's gone and now I'm
working on the next
and if I do get feedback later on then
yes I'll go back to that but right now
if it's out in the contest and it's out
to executives of any sort managers
producers or whatever that's gone on to
the next thing so it sounds like a fine
line between having a bunch of yes
people in your life versus saboteurs
because there could be people that may
say it's bad when it's actually great
yeah finding that that that fine cuz
it's not easy to find the middle ground
no and I think it's I think you get much
more of one side though I think you get
much more than yes people I think people
are very you know we were having a
conversation the other day and they said
the the biggest enemy of a creative is
the person who tells you yes all the
time
the person that you know it's you want
somebody that's that's going to be
honest you don't want
well the person's can be nice to you I
think was the the way where you put it
like the person is just gonna be nice
you know want people to be nice want
people to be honest okay most people are
gonna read you work are gonna be nice if
they're your friends and family and
people that or your acquaintances or
your trading scripts with another writer
and that writers gonna go oh you know it
was it was terrific and you know that's
not good for you know no growth comes
from that like it's the same thing when
you have debate with people like you
know a discussion with people you know
growth comes from debate well growth as
a writer comes from getting honest
feedback or any you know creative
pursuit really I mean you know you want
honest feedback was that good in that
scene you know you weren't so great in
that scene if you're an actor you know I
mean you want to get that feedback what
did I do wrong what did I you know same
thing as a writer so you want to find I
don't you know if you're finding people
that are being saboteurs I mean I think
that you're probably surrounding
yourself with the absolutely wrong
people but I think again if you're
giving yourself up to a consultant or
somebody that's doing coverage for you
you have done your homework and you're
you're gonna you have gotten yourself to
a position where you say I trust this
Pete there's this person implicitly I'm
giving it to them and I'm gonna be very
receptive to that feedback which of
course by the way is the other part of
the battle is they have to be receptive
yeah you know
you